Hey Jocko,
I'm a business owner in the beginning stages of merging with another company.
The other company doesn't know much about what we do,
but has the sales and marketing,
marketing we need just at a conference with just at a conference call with them
and it didn't go well.
They're wanting to change the pay structure for contractors as well as change
how we build our customers. All the offer, the benefit of money to Ching,
let's save some money on that one. Isn't it not a good idea to have,
have the primary mission be about money in more so on the success of the
customer or is it good to be money motivated? I,
I have and enjoy all your books. Oh yeah, that's cool. Advice
could be helpful.
So that means you read the dichotomy of leadership hope because this is the
answer of the day. Need to be more balanced. Okay, so if you're money hungry,
right? Which is what this is sounding like. If you're money hungry, correct.
If you're money hungry, you're going to cut corners on product.
The product is going to be weak or, or low quality.
You're going to do wrong by the customer, right? Cause when you,
when you get a chance to, you know, the customer, the customer placed an order,
a double order by accident, they click the click thing twice and it will,
they just gonna have to pay that restocking fee, you know, whatever.
Like whatever the thing is, right?
You treat customers like that and they're gonna go, okay,
well we don't really want to shop with you anymore and you end up with a bad
reputation and the quality is low and no, eventually you have no more business.
That's what's gonna happen. So, so no,
we can't go hardcore money grubbing just that's our,
that's our focus. Other end of the spectrum
is
hey, we're paying our contractors too much. Ken, is that possible? Yes,
it's possible. You're giving your customers too much,
you're giving them too good of a price point and guess it was now going to
happen. Same thing. You're going to not have a business anymore. So one,
you have a, you, your business goes out of business because your,
because you don't have any business anymore cause you've treated your customers
bad. And the contractors don't want to work with you so you have,
you end up shutting down. This one's opposite your, everyone loves you,
you just don't have any money so you're going out of business even at all.
So there has to be some balance. You have to find the right balance.
That's what every company is trying to do.
Now I would say that you would,
where you want to lean, and this is probably what you're thinking.
You want to lean toward taking care of the customer.
You want to lean toward giving the contractors good value for their work.
You want to lean toward high quality.
The reason you want to lean towards those things as those were all long term
strategic pay offs, right? What's the short term?
The short term is take advantage of the customers.
The short term is screw over the contractors.
The short term is put out low quality stuff. We make good profit this quarter,
but it's a short, it's a term when it's a long time, long term loss,
so that's why I would say lean, don't go out of control.
You can't go out of control in that direction,
but you can lean towards that direction. Now as far as the new company,
the merger and all this stuff, get it. I get it. Here's what's going to happen.
What you need to go and build good relationships with those people.
The new company,
they need to be your best friends because if you build relationships with them,
then you can have influence over these points.
If you have an antagonistic relationship and you're the new guy or whatever,
like, Oh yeah, the new company, you think they don't.
You're saying that they would, as you say, they don't know what we do. Right.
What do you think they think? They think you don't know what they do.
They're thinking, you know what? You don't even, hey you guys make good money.
Might make good product but you can't sell anything.
And we got sales and we got marketing. We could sell anything.
We don't care what it looks like. We don't care what the quality is.
That's what they're thinking. Yeah.
So you need to form a relationship with them because I will tell you with their
sales and marketing, if you're making a good product,
that's how we get the big time win.
But if you have an antagonistic relationship with them, uh,
it'll all fall apart and you won't have any influence at all.
And they'll be like, you don't even know what you're talking about, dude.
We're just going to jack the price even more and we're going to undercut our pro
contractors. We're gonna get contractors competing with each other.
They're going to hate each other. They're going to hate us,
but it doesn't matter. Looking at our bottom line.
So build some relationships there.